Hey, Sofia.
Sophia.
Hey, Jeremy.
So.
How are you?
Friday. Pretty good.
Yeah, Friday.
My wife is with her girlfriend in the
living room. Like, who's Jeremy?
Oh, sorry. Yeah, it's late for you. So.
So I was a little confused because so
next week you go off summertime,
but we're still on daylight savings time
Oh, so it's not even a word yet.
for one week. Yeah,
it's it happens every year. So yeah,
there's a we go a week early and we go
off a week late. So I thought that.
It.
That I had it in my head that this was
gonna oh, it's only 7 hours to the UK,
but.
Yeah, yeah, it's OK. Sorry.
What time is it for you? Is it like 10?
How's Rob?
10.
OK, makes sense.
Yeah. AJ.
AG.
I don't think we hear you. There we go.
Now I hear you. Yeah. Yeah. Happy Friday.
Talking on mute. Sorry. How are you doing?
It's Friday afternoon.
you do.
How have you been?
Haven't talked in a while.
I know, right? Yeah, I'm good. Thanks.
How are you?
Pretty good. Pretty good. Yep.
Gonna give Surreal a moment.
So Surreal is our new principal data
scientist.
You may remember a fellow called Suresh.
He left us a while back and Surreal is
now filling that role,
so we're hoping he can help us out with
his POC.
Alright, cool. Sounds good.
I'm about to start bugging you again,
Sophia, next week, so sorry.
Now that we're close to go live for
fusion,
I'm going to be hounding you back on your
radar for enhancement stuff.
Sure, sure, no problem. Yeah,
I think I saw a couple of tickets.
Thanks.
I'm not sure this is all relevant to data
science.
Yeah.
I saw some a ticket about site resolution.
Some of the sites were not properly
resolved, right?
Yeah, but honestly,
I think that's probably gonna sort itself
out in the next month when we have the
feedback loop.
I'm not too concerned about that.
I'm talking more like new stuff,
Yeah.
OK. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, new stuff. Yeah,
sure. The time frames and um,
which is cool and exciting, so.
Cool.
I guess the enhancements we want to
implement, yeah.
Structured results. Yeah,
there's a couple of things I think that,
Nice. Yeah, that sounds interesting.
yeah.
The.
Cool. Glad. Me too. I think so too.
I also,
Yeah.
I guess while we're waiting that the
protocols we parsed.
So I know we just parsed and stored them
for now,
but there's getting a lot of interest on
pulling out pieces of it in specific ways.
So that was the other thing I was going
to.
Could try to get on your radar. Cool.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Sure.
Meeting Surreal and see if he's able to
join. No, we'll just get started.
OK.
So to give you a little context, G,
we we know that this concept of health
network detection,
it might not be phrasing it the right way,
but has come up as something that we
would be interested in looking at and we
have one person on our team who's a a
contractor.
Who does the UI work for our knowledge
graph UI and as well as some other sort
of back end work.
And he's finished the work he's working
OK.
on and we have him until the end of the
year. So the thought was, well,
let's see if we we know we have this
concept we want to do a PAC for.
Let's see if we can get it in,
but we still have this guy who can help
us a bit.
OK, cool. Awesome.
And um,
why don't you go ahead and just start?
Tell us what the problem was,
what the use case is,
and what we're trying to solve for.
G.
Oh, OK, sure. Sorry. I can tell you.
I can tell you what mine is. Yeah.
Yes, tell us your use case.
All right,
so there's a bunch of stuff baked into
this.
Sorry,
I'm trying to think of where to start.
Basically,
we're getting different flavors of
requests of relationships between various
types of things that are called networks.
Just a little bit of background in that
the the definition of this,
none of these are very well defined,
which is part of the work I'm starting
next week is to get a better handle on
what we as Norstella think our
definitions are,
but the various flavors of things that we
hear about are.
Site networks,
which seems to range from sites that work
together to sites that share financial
ties to sites that share administrative
ties. Health networks,
which seems to run the gamut of
definitions of insurance companies,
insurance networks,
loose disease networks of unrelated.
Sites and hospitals, hospital networks,
etc.
We also have heard of interest about
referral networks,
which could be sites or people,
and they could be related from an
organization level or not.
And then there was another one in there
too. So anyway, Long story short,
there's like various levels of things
where we need to decide on.
Definitions and taxonomy. But past that,
once we have those things in place,
which we are starting on,
I think we have really good structure and
fusion to do some really cool,
interesting stuff with it.
But we're going to need to somehow map
and apply all of this structure once we
have it.
And that's where I'm a little stuck is
that I can see in my head that there will
be lots of relationships.
There will be relationships between the
person master and the org master and the
trial master.
And like I can see that the need for the
relationships,
we have the structure and the taxonomy in
place once we have that.
How do we then apply it and map it?
And I know there's some pieces of
referral information in the RWD set also,
like you can see what doctor referred a
patient to another doctor,
but that's kind of even a separate thing
in that they might not necessarily even
be in the same network or know each other.
I guess there's a lot of pieces floating
around that are very vague right now.
I know that there's structure needed on
the definition side and what we as
Norstella think it should be.
But once we have that,
how do I then go and apply that to the
existing data set in a way that's not?
Someone manually doing it, I guess.
So there's a couple things baked in there,
but I guess that's kind of like the
overall problem.
Want to give that a go, Sofia,
or do you want me to try?
Yeah,
I mean obviously there is the technical
aspects of building relationships and
graphs to to kind of unveil, you know,
connections between between different
nodes or entities,
but I am more interested in.
What the product looks like,
what kind of what kind of insights do we
want to provide? Is this, you know,
a chatbot?
Is this some kind of dashboard where we
could see connections between different
sites?
It's more about the delivery and having.
Top down approach and then we can think
about the technical aspects, but um,
I I don't know if you have any.
Oh, from my perspective,
obviously I want the data.
I want all the data structured and and
relationships between it.
OK.
And so that's I guess kind of my end
product,
but from an actual product what we're
going to sell type of place.
It seems to be coming up in various Rd.
maps,
so I think I heard there's a piece in.
ISS where they want to have some sort of
a metric that they're somehow surfacing
networks together.
There's a referral network piece that's
coming up with what product PSD or ISS,
one of the smart solutions.
Yeah.
So there's kind of I'm hearing about it
in multiple other places,
but I've also been on very quite a few
client calls recently where everyone
agrees that there's no standard
definition in out there.
Everyone agrees that everyone's using the
terminology too loosely.
And people are asking us,
clients are asking us,
what is your version of the taxonomy and
can we use it and buy it?
So I think there's quite a few ways that
we could use this once we have it.
Yeah.
And that's kind of,
I guess from my my perspective too,
I want to make sure I future-proof this
as much as possible because I think it
would be.
Products also, Sophie.
So I I guess I'm a little,
I don't want to get too tied down into
what it looks like on the other end
because I think once we have it,
it could end up in quite a few places.
Make sense? Yep.
And I think my I would start at a higher
level of I'm just going to say
abstraction,
which is what are the I understand all of
these things at a conceptual level and
yeah, they need to be defined of course,
blah blah, and you're very data savvy,
so you've got all of that.
But what are the value propositions?
Like why do clients want to know these
things and what are they going to do with
this information?
So the last piece I talked about is they
want to take their internal data and
apply our structure to it.
So they want to structure their internal
databases with network information and
who works together.
I've heard other cases of clients wanting
to.
Identify networks so that they can use
sites that are in the same network as an
existing site they've already used before.
I think for ISS they want to be able to
provide metrics around investigators that.
Are in the same network or in the same
referral network, site work,
network or referral network.
So I guess there's quite a few,
there's quite a few that I've heard of so
far.
Yeah, there's a few things there. Yeah.
So metrics and analytics is a pile of use
cases.
I can that that makes perfect sense.
Yep.
I'm sure that will come up many times
IDing sites for trials. I mean,
that's a different way of,
I think what we're talking about is a
different way of solving a problem that
we already have some.
Sort of solution for right?
Like isn't there a way in trial trove or
site trove to go in and and part of the
purpose of that product right is like I
have a trial I'm looking for sites so.
You can see the sites that are associated
with a given trial.
You can't see beyond that two sites that
work together regularly.
OK.
And I think that is one of the desires is
to once,
especially with now that there are
financial and capability of relationships
between a lot of these site networks is
to find like, OK, I know I'm,
I know I've been successful with this
site that has this capability.
I would like to expand that and find the
other sites that, yeah,
Right.
so there's the kind of that piece of it
too.
Show me the friends of my friends. Yeah,
yeah, get that.
Yeah,
I think there's also desire to use some
of the proprietary data in a way also.
So once we have the networks,
you could then do some metrics around.
This network has a better shorter site
activation time frame than this network
because you could link the site.
We have it at site level,
but not any higher than that.
So everything would can be rolled up at
that point into a higher network score,
Got it.
yeah.
So some sort, yeah,
that so that makes sense.
And then the first thing that you said
was users want to take our our take their
internal data and apply our structure to
it.
Yes.
And to me I would split that into sort of
two basic sets of use cases.
One of them is is joining data where they
want to have a way to take their
proprietary data that only they have and
join it to our data in their environment
or a neutral environment or a safe
environment to increase.
Their capabilities,
another which another one would be I
think more literally what you said,
which was they just want to know how to
organize their data so that they can.
They want a standardized structure that
will make sense in the world,
that will be understandable to other
folks that will allow them to organize
their data and get.
Information and value out of it.
Um, yes, I think. I think more the latter.
I think that they.
OK.
Probably can do more of the former
without this because they could still,
I think join based on what we because
they don't have the network information.
It's not like they have it in there you
they would use it to bridge to ours.
Nobody has it. It's kind of the.
Big gap in the and and everybody starts
talking about it and throwing around the
terms very loosely and it's a very hot
but like hot words right now,
but nobody really knows what it means.
OK, so I want to drill down on that.
You said nobody has the network
information.
So tell us exactly what is this
information that nobody has?
A structured definition and taxonomy of
what they consider a network.
OK.
So.
So that's I wouldn't call that
information, I would call that.
Well, let's.
I don't know the right way to say this,
but it did a definition, a taxonomy.
So it's.
A definition and a and a and categories.
So yeah.
Right,
which would then be populated with data
to produce information.
I would, I would tag.
I would use it to add attributes to
If I understand correctly the.
existing site profiles and investigator
profiles and things like that.
So I guess I would,
I would think it lives in graphite once
we have it and then we apply it to. Sorry,
maybe I'm not understanding the question.
Yeah,
let me rephrase the question more simply.
And now I'm not articulating myself very
well at the moment,
but so the there's one problem which
could be that, you know,
people just don't know how sites relate
to each other.
And then then there's another more
fundamental problem is people don't know
OK.
what it means for a site to relate to
another site.
People don't have the.
Yes,
and they have differing and they have
differing definitions.
So one person is saying one saying the
Yes.
same term and they think and it's meaning
two different things to two different
people.
So there's value in us as Norstella
saying, here's what a site is,
here's what a relationship is. Here's,
yeah,
We commit to it. We give you definitions.
Yep.
we here's a set of definitions and
taxonomies which you can then we can
populate relation.
We can build you a data structure.
We could build a data structure that
leverages those to.
Yep.
create networks, meetings, information,
value, blah, blah.
Yep.
You could also just take that set of
definitions and apply it to your data or
other data you want to buy, whatever.
Okay.
Yep.
So it's it's almost like building A
taxonomy based on relationship data that
we see happening, right? So.
Yes,
but I want to come at it from the other
direction at first.
I want to commit to our definitions of
what we as Norstella think,
because that's the other squishy part is
OK.
it's not just saying, well,
I want to map relationships that exist
like with existing definitions.
So I'm trying to think of an example.
Like trial similarity or something.
It's not just saying like which factors
are going to come up most often.
I think we need to even go back up a step
and say like this is what we are looking.
This is what we are looking for because
we don't even have a definition
definition at this point.
Right, OK.
We don't even know what to look at.
But.
It's fair to say that we want to go back,
come out and say like this is what we
Right.
So.
think is important when you connect sites
or when you frame a network of sites.
In other words,
just P is being overlapping with each
other. It is not a good enough metrics,
but we need to add other metrics that
define.
A coherence between the sites or that we
already.
Yeah, yeah.
I think that that feels like the next
step. Once we have definitions,
like then we start saying, OK,
we can now see the relationships and what
do we see as the most valuable
relationship, right?
Like these are the metrics we would use
to pull out. We consider these are.
Closer, further, whatever.
You know what I mean?
It's like you're right,
just cuz they have a relationship,
it doesn't necessarily mean it's a a
valuable one in depending on the
definition. But yeah, what do we?
And then that's a cool way to say,
is it number of interactions?
Like I could say see for a referral
network if you're referring someone
preferentially and you have 100.
Referrals.
That's better than someone who refers
twice. So just because they do,
they have a relationship.
It's more like there's there's quality
and quantity on top of it,
which would be really cool to do too.
But yeah, that's that's interesting.
So the one.
So let's say we create some definition or
definitions of what it means for networks
to be, for sites to be in a network,
members of the same network or not
members of the same network.
So one use of that that we've talked
about so far is.
I'm looking for sites for my trial.
I have a site that I've identified either
because I've worked with before,
because I whatever reason I know it's one
I want to work with.
Here's their here's ten other sites that
are part of that same network that I
might consider.
OK. Yes, yes, that does make sense.
Absolutely.
Does that make sense? OK, so.
I could see coming at it from the other
direction too.
If I have a set of trials that were
successful in this disease,
I know they were,
they were successful according to my
parameters.
I want to see the site networks that were
used most often with this set of trials.
Makes sense, yeah.
In order to select them to to attempt to
get them to be sites for my trial and
increase the probability that my trial is
successful.
If I'm a trial person or if I'm like a.
CRO,
I want to go build a relationship with
them because I know that they're going to,
do you know what I mean?
I think I could see some other reasons
from other types of clients too, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, right.
So it it's almost like some kind of site
success metric based on different
parameters like indication, you know,
location, other other entities basically.
Yeah.
Yeah,
cause more and more we're getting into
like.
Like CROS have relationships with
preferentially with sites and then
there's certain like entities that will
try to go out and get patients for sites
like there's a middle man,
like I think there's a couple of other
ancillary areas that are kind of cropping
up with these site networks.
Yeah.
But nobody has a handle on like where
they are, how they relate.
And it's interesting, but yeah,
very nebulous right now.
Makes sense. We had protocol recommender.
Now we're gonna have site recommender.
Yeah.
I could very much see there being like a,
That's great.
yeah,
site network recommender and like a
higher level. Yeah,
this is our preferential.
Yeah.
They they get a tier one versus a Tier 2,
yeah.
Makes sense.
Very interesting.
And then I think the other technical
challenge is at that point,
once we have all of this, like how do we,
how do we apply it to all of the existing
data? Cause the data sets are so large.
That's the other thing in the back of my
head is I I can't do it manually very
easily.
And I don't know if there's a better way
to do that once we have. Yeah,
I I don't know.
I don't know what to do with it at that
First, that's.
So Surreal and Sofian are going to be mad
at me, but scale's not a problem.
point.
OK, awesome. Great. Made my day.
Don't worry about that.
But.
Jeremy here, I, I, I, you know,
I think we're not using Excel if that
makes you, uh, feel more comfortable.
No, no, no.
It's more of like a primary endpoints
Yes.
problem, Sophian, right?
Like we're going to end up having to go
back and do it to everything eventually.
I can just see it coming,
even if we restrict it to a certain set
to start.
Yeah, and and if scale is a problem,
we could even focus on a given
therapeutic area or a given indication.
You know,
Mhm.
we can be smart about it for a proof of
concept.
We don't need to do it for every single
indication or every single size, right?
OK, OK, cool.
The the good thing is that the fusion
data that we're going to have is going to
be highly structured,
way better than what we had before.
Yeah.
It's going to be connected to different
masters, different data sets, so.
It will be great from a a technical
standpoint because this is exactly I
think the value of fusion being able to
link different data points together.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, no, it's actually really exciting,
especially kind of.
I know we ran into a couple of bumps with
the primary endpoints,
like nothing we could have known about,
but now that we've,
it's almost like a simpler primary
endpoints problem, right?
Like we're going to need to do it to the
big set,
but we already did it with once with
those things.
We already can do that piece, but.
Yeah,
I just don't know how to get from point A
Sorry.
Yeah, no, that makes sense.
to point B.
Cool. Thank you.
Yeah.
So from my side, yeah,
we're starting the the kind of the
So.
background thought work on what we want
to commit to for definitions and
structure next week.
So I'm hoping to have at least something
OK.
fairly quickly.
But I was trying to think through if
there was a piece we could do to kind of
jumpstart things right away, Jeremy,
to your point of trying to like get
something going and I think there were.
Referral section might be the way to go
because I know that we can pull out that
relationship from the RWD. Well,
I I understand that we can pull out the
relationship from RWD of the referrals.
If there was a way to somehow start there,
that might be a thing that doesn't need
as much structure from my side and then
that kind of.
Gives me some time to get the definitions
and stuff in place because we are we know
that that referral information is already
in that set.
Yeah, um.
That just sounds too easy.
It just sounds too easy.
OK, so stepping back a little bit,
So what what do we need in practical
terms over the next,
let's just say week or two to be able to
have something before we all go away at
the end of the year?
So we need a working definition of what
it means for sites to be connected for
some use case or set of use cases.
And you've said that Gee,
you're gonna you're working on that now
with folks and there's some conversation.
We're starting it.
I definitely won't be within two weeks.
Working working definition is fine.
Working definition is fine.
It's a it's a bear and you're well, OK,
there's a there's a lot there.
I know it seems fairly straightforward
come up with a definition,
but there's so much I think that we need
to consider in on multiple definitions
that I don't know that I can do that in
two weeks,
Mhm.
which is kind of why I was trying to.
OK.
Figure out a middle ground.
I also don't have any data once I have
Right.
that for the fusion side.
So what I meant for the RWD data,
I guess that would be my curious part too,
is I don't have access to it.
I can't see it. Whatever they can,
whatever they have for referral
Mhm.
relationships might be very.
Helpful for us to inform definitions and
structure of a category for that stuff.
I don't know what is in there though,
so I can't see it. I don't, yeah.
Yeah,
we can walk you through that at a high
level and we have access to that.
Surreal has access to that.
So when you say you don't have data for
the future site,
does that mean there's no such thing as a
site master?
There is an org master that contains
clinical sites.
So the Yeah, exactly. No, no,
I was going to say the exact same.
OK.
They have. Sorry, go ahead, Sufian.
They they have a parent-child structure
and relationship right now, but the site.
OK.
So I have the bones in place to apply A
tag, a network tag.
I don't have the taxonomy.
I I have a very very limited list right
now of what.
Would go there and I don't know that it's
going to be sufficient.
So I guess that's the other kind of
problem.
Until I know how many levels and what the
taxonomy looks like and all of that stuff,
I don't know what I need to apply to the
master.
OK.
Like I I'm new here,
so when we say organizational master,
let's say if there is Yale, right?
So that means that we'll have a a master
data set for Yale and then every site
within the Yale network would have.
Would we consider them as sites
individually or am I thinking about it
completely wrong?
I'm I'm sorry, can you say that again?
I think he's asking what is what is a
site?
What is the organizational master like?
What is that organizational level and
Oh, OK. Well, the, yeah,
I'm not the PO for the org master,
what is the site level?
but my understanding is that the
organization definition of a parent
organization is that they are in a
standalone entity that has financial
independence and there's a couple of
other financial pieces in there.
So mostly the clinical sites are child
have a child relationship to the parent
because the parent is usually the kind of
overarching financial thing that drives
it.
So you do have stand-alone sites that
have themselves as a parent.
Mhm.
It doesn't happen super often.
Mostly the the sites are have a
controlling organization in the org
master,
which I do think needs to feed into this
somehow, but it's not really a network,
it's more of a owned by situation.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
It's ownership relationships and and I
Yeah, yeah.
think it's very incomplete.
I'm sure there are other relationships
Yeah.
that are like ownership relationships
that are happening in real life,
but not in the database.
Yes, yes, yes.
We've done a lot of clean up,
Right.
but I think it I I totally take your
point and completely agree that there's
probably more that can be done there and
it's only a two level hierarchy,
which I would argue probably needs to be
more like 3 or 4, but.
And.
So.
It's thorny, right, Jeremy?
It's a thorny problem.
Of course it is. Yeah, I just try to take.
I want one thorn at a time. So um.
Yeah.
Providers and sites are not one to one.
Correct.
Is is there value?
Would there be value in since we don't
yet have that so basic a basic definition
or understanding of what does it mean for
sites to be connected?
What if we did a a provider network?
What if we started there and we said
let's try to figure out what makes
providers connected and you know,
there are the first, you know,
many ways to do that. Patients, diseases,
drugs, relationships to sites.
Um.
For all that works.
Does that become then an input or a facet
or some other related useful information?
Yeah,
I definitely think that's part of it.
4.
I totally agree.
And that's kind of what I think that
OK.
that's probably a better,
more elegant way of what I was trying to
get at with the referral piece is that
feels a little bit more manageable right
now. So yeah,
I totally agree and it probably can span
much wider than just referrals.
Like if you want to,
we do have the site to person
relationships.
And we do capture as they move between
organizations. So that data is in fusion.
OK.
You could go back and see previous sites
and organizations they were affiliated
with.
We haven't done anything with it yet
Yeah. And and I know even in one, right.
And even at one point in time,
though.
Yeah.
a provider might be affiliated with
multiple sites. So yeah, so Surreal,
Yes, yes, they might. Yep.
this is a question I don't know the
answer to,
but is it do we know and maybe you don't
yet, but in the RWD?
Or clinical visit. Do we know?
Let's say a provider works at, you know,
has their own private practice and works
at two hospitals.
Do we know where that visit took place?
I don't know the answer to that,
but I think we can figure that out. Yeah.
Yeah, OK.
That would be cool. That would be, yeah,
a great first step, yeah.
Yeah, I think maybe we should start there.
I think maybe we should start with the
provider level and try to come up with
some way of, you know,
for lack of a more elegant way of saying
it, clustering providers.
Mhm.
Uh.
No, that'd be cool.
That'd be really interesting too,
if we could somehow have them.
Have the relationship with the site with
the referral because then that could get
matched to our.
Site information and fusion.
That also might be an interesting
bridging way between the data too. OK,
that would be cool.
Yep.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and and there could be some pretty short
And.
step.
Let's say we had a robust way of
clustering providers,
having similarity metrics and and having
networks and so forth.
There could be a a short step to a a
first version of sites just by.
Aggregating those metrics along different
axes.
Yeah.
And also surreal.
I think that that's also going to be
useful for all the things that MIT wants
to do.
I agree and I think that even if there is
like not a one-to-one relationship
between provider and sites,
I think at that point we'll probably just
at the first pass just want to find like
a simpler aggregation methodology like
hey.
If the the numbers are like 60% or higher
at one site,
then that's the primary site and then
everything else becomes secondary one MVP
Yeah.
level, yeah.
Yeah.
OK,
so back to trying to turn this into
Yes.
something practical and concrete.
So our working definition of what we're
trying to define,
we've decided it's going to be provider
networks.
And that in the meantime,
she's gonna go away and work with all the
smart people and define what a a site
network means and then get back to us.
Surreal has access to the data,
the RGBD data.
What data are there data or what data are
there in fusion that we can use the
leverage to make this?
more robust or more complete.
Sure.
The person master is probably going to be
the place where you're going to find the
providers.
It's in UAT right now and it'll be in
production on November 11th.
All goes well, knock on wood. Yeah.
And and in the meantime,
OK.
we'll come at the.
Kind of overarching definitions and
structure.
I do think it'll end up encompassing the
provider stuff that you're talking about,
but in a way that hopefully we can tag
and apply. I don't think it, you know,
changes anything that it sounds like
you're going to do as a first pass anyway,
but but we'll have that.
We'll have a kind of a hopefully what I'm
Mhm.
hoping for is to come out of it.
With a robust set of definitions and
relationships and hierarchy and
categories that we can use and apply
across everything.
OK,
what's the what are the data sources for
the person master?
How does how does information get in
there?
Currently it is primarily investigators
and industry staff and trial support
staff.
So it's based off of usually the trial
information, public sources,
so trial registries, press releases,
OK.
medical websites, NPI provider database.
Got it.
Yeah, I'd love PubMed.
I'd love to get that more robust.
I think there's a couple of places we
could get more data that we didn't have a
place for until now because this is
primarily data that was stored in star
for site trove and but obviously person
master could be more than just
investigators,
but that's the primary source right now.
OK, OK. Yeah, I can definitely see that.
I can definitely imagine that real-world
data would be able to augment that,
but those two things are gonna,
they're gonna, they're not gonna.
There will be places where they don't
Yeah.
overlap and they can compliment each
other.
Yeah, yeah, no, definitely be awesome.
I think MPI number is probably the
For sure.
easiest entry into that.
So if anything you're running surreal is
can include that,
that might make our kind of data mappings
a little easier.
Yeah.
OK,
so we have a high level definition of
what we're trying to do.
We have data sources.
I think the other thing that we kind of
need is, you know, again,
for lack of a better term,
some sort of objective function like.
What do we get? What would we look at?
So let's say Surreal goes away and he
comes back and he produces a table and
the table has like provider one,
provider two and then some of the data
about how they're already or it has a
provider and has all their relationships
with strength, confidence,
blah blah blah blah.
Um.
What do we look at or what do we measure
to understand if this is telling us what
we want to know?
I'd probably without being able to see
our WT data directly.
I'm kind of making a bit of a guess in
the dark,
but for me it would be kind of like a
number of hits situation,
like how many times that they are
interacting. So if you've got someone.
A provider referring to one other
specific provider more often.
To me that's a stronger relationship and
I guess you could expand that to say.
If you could aggregate the sites within a
network,
how often do they refer within within
site network versus outside site network?
But I think that needs kind of the other
pieces to inform it,
but that would be the things I think most
interesting at first.
OK.
I don't know, Sophie,
and you've seen all the person in site
data.
Anything else you can think of that I'm
not come out of RWD?
Um.
I'm thinking we may not have a good
answer to this question until there's
Uh.
more definition around the definitions of
sites and relationships and things like
that. But you know, it's really,
it's really, I mean, it's really easy.
Yeah.
It's relatively easy to aggregate a bunch
of data and show some stats.
The question is like.
Are we building?
If we're saying 2 providers are part of
the same network or they have this
relationship,
are we doing it in a way that is
meaningful for what?
the use cases that our clients want to
use it for.
OK. I think I see what you're saying.
I think, yeah,
then it's definitely volume of
interactions because I don't necessarily
care if they've only interacted a couple
of times.
I care that they've have an ongoing
relationship more. And so to me,
Yeah.
it's almost like a a range or a value,
right? If you have more relationships,
you get whatever ranked higher,
higher score, whatever if you're.
Fewer relationships means looser
connection, lower score.
I'm just, I'm just throwing stuff out.
I don't really know what it looks like.
Yeah, no, that's OK. That's OK. Yeah,
this is all a proof of concept.
We're just trying to make trying to.
Come up with something that gives some
sort of sense of what we're going to look
Do.
at at the end.
OK, yeah.
So like from my, I come from Cigna, right?
And we always try to figure out which
providers were referring to which other
providers and that was one of the biggest
Yeah.
problems to solve because referral.
Was not something that was captured
accurately, right?
I'm wondering if that's similar in RWD
notes here because I haven't looked at
OK.
them because the the the workaround we
found was how many.
Members were shared across providers,
so not a direct referral measure,
but more of a measure as this member is
common between them in the last year and
that's why they are like connected
somehow.
Is there actual patients itself? Yeah,
yeah.
You mean the actual patient as a member?
OK, yeah. No, that's, yeah,
So I'm trying to figure out if the refer,
yeah.
that makes sense to me.
I don't know what their data looks like.
So I can't really, you know,
if that if that's an interesting metric
too and and that's more reliable,
that would be interesting.
I I don't know what they're. Yeah,
I'm not as familiar with their data.
But with referrals,
do we think that our referral data is
very clean and good or we don't know that?
I don't know. Yeah, I don't.
I don't have any access to that data.
So it's a good question. Totally agree.
Would love to know about that.
Yeah, yeah, I think so. Yeah, there's two,
there are two. Well,
the first question is,
is that referral captured in EHR
Yeah.
structured data? And if it's not,
it's definitely captured where it is
recorded.
And note summaries.
So for example,
I'm just pulled up the viewer right here.
Like the text. Yeah,
the the notes text is problematic. Agree.
Yeah.
Yes, we spent all we're working with it.
We spent a lot of time working with it
Yeah.
and and it's also obfuscated in many ways.
So where it says referral to psychology.
Yes.
We don't know who that is.
We don't know who that provider is.
The only way to guess about who that
provider is reasonable would be in that
patient's history,
who's the which is the next provider that
they saw whose specialty is psychology.
Which doesn't mean that that's the person
they were referred to necessarily,
but it's a pretty good guess.
Yeah,
I I guess they could be also because you
Yep, agree.
know, again, I'm not part of the RWD team,
so I my knowledge is very limited here,
but it seems like extracting that data
from text is quite complex,
Yes.
especially at scale I think.
Yep.
I would probably consider proxies for
referrals. For example, a proxy.
Good proxy in my opinion could be you
take a patient ID,
you look at the different.
Persons, the different, you know,
medical experts,
that person visited in a short amount of
time and that's a likely referral, right?
So I don't know if I go to a doctor,
a generalist and two days after I go.
Yeah.
I go to check, I don't know.
I have the words in French coming up,
but it's difficult to. Yeah,
but let's say if I go see a specialist
Paid in French.
two days apart from my general
appointment, it's probably a referral,
Yeah.
right?
So the timestamps of visits should be
quite informative or could be used as a
proxy for referrals.
Yeah.
Yes.
What's the second point? Yeah.
Yeah.
Right.
Next visit,
because usually that would be you'd get
Right.
the more generalist visit and then the
next visit after it is the specialist.
That might be interesting.
I don't know.
Yeah, all right. And
Yeah, I mean,
it can get more complicated than that too.
Like, so let's say that I I go to my GP,
they refer me to a dermatologist.
I get appointment in six months.
In the meantime,
I go back to my GP and they refer me to a
podiatrist.
Podiatrist sees me the next day.
You know,
it's like I think that there has to be
more than dates and NP is to figure out
kind of which goes to which.
Yeah, of course. I mean,
it's definitely not a perfect metric,
but if we have proxies,
I think at a very large scale you could
Yeah.
potentially have some trends here.
I I agree with you,
Yeah, for sure.
it's it's it's not perfect data.
Or like you said,
maybe layering in a couple of like,
that's one factor. But then also,
you know, anytime you see a,
like you said, Jeremy, a specialist,
you know,
and then the note says the same specialty,
maybe that's another piece.
Maybe there's a few pieces here we need
to kind of string together.
Yeah, yeah.
And the the referral can have like a
weight or a confidence score associated
with it. It doesn't have to be binary.
So if we come up with some simple
OK.
heuristics for that,
then that can further inform the
probability that these two people are in
these two providers are in a network.
Interesting.
We have also seen that generally within a
referral generally happens within the
same group of providers or same hospital
systems or same Yale of the provider.
So like Yale would very unlikely refer to
someone outside of Yale.
That's just how they were exactly.
But that's an interesting metric, right?
So that's the thing I don't want to,
but I don't want to hard.
I don't want to focus that way because I
would be interested to see when they
don't refer within their network.
I think that's the other really
interesting thing to clients is to make
OK.
sure we capture that other piece too is
like when they go outside.
How often are they going outside?
Why are they going outside?
That type of thing?
Yeah.
Yeah. Great. Cool. Thanks.
Persync.
All right, so Sophia and Surreal,
do you feel like you have enough
information and context to get started?
Enough to be dangerous.
That's all we want to know.
And I guess Sophia is really more is
playing a supportive role here,
but I I imagine Sril's going to need some
help with access to fusion data and
Definitely. Yeah,
I have a pretty good understanding of the
understanding what it is.
Yes.
Yeah.
different tables that are used in fusion.
So if you have any questions or need
access to different tables,
then let me know. I'll be happy to help.
Sounds perfect. I'll set up some time.
Sounds good.
And and just so that like I'm clear,
like we are still thinking looking at all
Oh.
the structure data that we have and not
really going to focus on RWD notes and
like trying to go through that like if if
we can do something with the structure
data that we have, that's our first pass.
I mean, I agree with that,
but I think I'm happy to leave that to
your discretion.
OK, that's fair.
Yeah.
Oh, thank you. Sounds good.
Thank you. Thank you.
Cool. All right. Thanks everyone.
Thanks for your time.
Thanks. Talk to you later.
Have a good weekend.
Thank you so much. Have a good weekend.
Bye, bye.
Thanks guys.
Thanks. Bye, guys.
Bye, bye.